I'm in the English countryside near
Canterbury and this is a level crossing
nothing too unusual about that except
and they are fairly few and far between
this little red and green light here
tells you when it's safe to cross and
then when it is you have to get out of
the car you drove up here like this in
parts of England in the valleys of Wales
on smaller lines but the thing you might
not know is that this is not a
provincial line this is a high-speed
rail line that has javelin trains on the
London to Ramsgate run the ones that do
140 miles an hour and okay they're not
doing 140 here they're doing about 40
maybe 50 miles an hour at most but all
that stopping me from blocking this line
or worse being hit by something on this
line is well this crossing and this
little lever down here that drops the
barriers and makes it safe for the
trains to cross again that is a user
operated level crossing and that is
something you might not have known